Susan Faludi author of the best-selling
backlash the undeclared war against
American women why do you think this
book has been so successful well I can
only judge by the letters I've received
from so many women and these women say
over and over again in fact it's almost
it's eerie incessant
one person is writing the same letter
10,000 times and these women will say in
these letters I thought I was the only
one feeling this way in the 80s I
thought that I was the only one who
thought that there were all these
pressures to tell me to back off
and nobody else was talking about us so
I just thought I was crazy and which was
quite similar to the feeling I had as a
writer writing the book so I think what
happened is well as one person put it to
me she said it was as if we were all
standing around this pool waiting -
waiting for somebody to be the first to
dive in and there were a number of women
in the last year who who did the first
sort of diving maneuvers and maybe I was
one of them certainly Anita Hill was one
Paula Coughlin who took on the Navy was
another and it only takes a couple of us
to to do that swan dive into the pool to
in turn give courage to a lot of other
women who've been dying to do that
themselves so I think this was a year
when we all you know we all took the
plunge if you were to tell someone who's
never seen this book never read a word
about it what it contains in a minute or
so what would you tell him well
essentially what what I'm telling people
is that in the last at least the last
decade really ever since of the modern
wave of the women's movement got started
there has been this counter reaction or
backlash to put women back in their
place and it's based on a big lie if you
will that argues that everything that
that the women's movement inspired that
all of women's liberation has yielded
women's misery the true equality has
only brought true unhappiness to women
and this is a big lie on both fronts a
we certainly don't have true equality
women pay still greatly lags behind
men's we have in tiny representation in
politics we have one of the worst rape
rates and in the world and on the other
side that's true misery that women
supposedly have as supposedly are facing
is not a result of too much feminism but
not enough women are feeling pain
because
the women's movement has not gone far
enough they do they are not treated
equally at work they're not treated
equally in the home and they have almost
no voice in in the formal political
institutions and the national discourse
in this country how many copies of this
hardback version have you sold last time
I checked it was more than 200,000 but I
haven't I haven't looked in a while when
you started the project did you dream
that it would sell 10,000 fine and what
I imagined into sell as many copies as
my mother bought it at the time when I
was writing in the depths of the mid 80s
and late 80s some people weren't talking
about feminism except to say disparaging
things about it it was it was not a time
when people felt comfortable talking
about anything political I think that
was one of the big the the the biggest
sort of impediments to advancing women's
cause or advancing any kind of
progressive cause in the eighties was
that so many ideas were reframed as
psychological problems rather than
political ideas so the the big women's
issues in the 80s were 12-step programs
or helping women to cure themselves of
the women who love too much syndrome
problems were always framed as there's
something wrong with you the woman
rather than there's something wrong with
the way society is structured that we
need to challenge when did you first sit
down to write this well it started as an
article about a rather celebrated
a story in Newsweek which I'm sure a lot
of women remember with much pain it was
a a cover story in Newsweek about the
so-called man shortage a Newsweek
reported breathlessly that the
harvard-yale marriage study had found
that women over 30 were more likely to
be killed by a terrorist than marry now
anyone whose past remedial math I've
been able to figure out that there was
something wrong with with their
arithmetic but this this story made the
rounds because no television shows it
was in Hollywood it was on greeting
cards and of course dating service
manuals and I wondered about it and as a
journalist at the time I decided to take
a closer look at it where were you I was
a reporter at the San Jose Mercury News
on the Sunday magazine and within the
first phone call to the Census Bureau I
smelled a rat first of all there was no
man shortage there was actually a woman
shortage in the primary age years and
furthermore there were a host of
problems with the study itself with a
sample with the way that the model to
make these projections was set up and
the Harvard Yale researchers ultimately
retracted the statistics themselves
this however got no front-page coverage
as I began to that was sort of the
beginning of my thinking about well if
this study is invalid why was it so
eagerly embraced by the media and
furthermore what about all the other
popular claims about the plight of the
modern liberated woman such claims as
the infertility epidemic that women who
postpone childbearing for education and
jobs were facing this terrible
a plague of infertility and we're off
you know rushing to the infertility
treatment centers well it turned out
that that too was a myth that in fact
women particularly educated women who
most profited from the women's movement
were the very women whose infertility
rates were declining and in fact across
the country
a nationwide women's in fertility rate
was declining and it was actually men's
infertility rate that was on the rise as
you go through these and each of them
the so-called
women are all returning to the home the
mommy track tale would was a myth as
well and women were flooding into the
workplace and on top of that when when
surveyed in public opinion polls women
said over and over again in increasing
majorities that they did not want to go
back to the home and they did not want
even part-time or less pressure jobs
that they wanted more advancement more
opportunities more power where's home
well home for me right now is San
Francisco I'm from New York originally
City well actually I'm now at Stanford
on a journalist and fellowship I'm at
New York City originally
I'm originally from Queens and what did
your parents do my mother is a product
of The Feminine Mystique era in a way
she was a journalist who gave up her
career to marry and move to the suburbs
and is someone who in another era would
have been a professional journalist and
in many respects the the book has
informed by observing that her
experience and the experience of women
of her generation who discovered the
second wave of feminism what is the
feminine mystique era of the 50s and
early 60s
really I guess we'd have to date to the
discovery of the feminine mystique to
1963 when Betty Friedan's feminine
mystique was published and it was an
experience that women in the suburbs had
of waking up and wondering well you know
I have every kitchen appliance known to
man but as something very basic is
missing in my life
into the suburb where I grew up this Wis
discovery hit like a Mack truck in the
neighborhood and women when we went back
to school and back to work
and really found themselves many of them
for the first time what you Dan my
father is a photographer and he's an
immigrant from Hungary a survivor of the
Holocaust and in more of the
old-fashioned school of my wife works
although he very much believed as do
many traditional men interestingly that
well maybe they liked the wife sting and
how they they have higher aspirations
for their daughter and so we very much
wanted wanted me to succeed why is that
I think perhaps because one wants one
wants the best for one's children even
and one also wants a comfortable home I
mean the reactor bowl a home that's made
where you have all the comforts I mean I
think women if they had their druthers
when would have wives at home to it's
very nice to come home and have the
dinner on the table and not to have to
worry about taking out the garbage you
know we all like to be taken care of it
slips I think a human trait not just a
male is the Faludi name his name yes and
is that a Hungarian a thank you did you
have brothers and sisters I have a
brother also lives in San Francisco and
it's very much a family nest
when did you think that you were or when
did you start to say I'm a feminist or
think you were a feminist or are you I
what does it mean well I've always been
a feminist and it's largely it never it
was it was not a difficult concept for
me to digest or two or four and I never
actually as I said they never occurred
to me that there was a pejorative
connotation to it because I had been
taught from as early as I can remember
that to be a feminist simply meant was a
matter of self-respect and common sense
that to be a feminist means that you
believe that women should be treated
like full human beings and nothing more
nothing less so it always made sense to
me I think the importance of standing up
and calling yourself a feminist came a
little later I think it hits most women
when they leave the protected world of
school or college and enter the
workforce and to see the real-life
application of inequality were you
involved in a particular extracurricular
activities when you're in high school
well I actually I my first experience as
a journalist if you want to call her bad
was them when I was in fifth or sixth
grade I ran of the little school
newspaper and I remember running a
survey of my of the other students
asking them if they were in favor of the
ER a and what they thought about
abortion and
see whether what I thought were quite
innocuous questions and at the PTA
meeting the next the next PTA meeting a
leader of the local chapter of the John
Birch Society stood up and started
ranting about this this terrible radical
feminist student who had run this survey
and was polluting the children's minds
with these these terrible notions my my
parents who were both sitting in the
audience chuckling and halfway through
them the mic cut off she was unaware of
this speaker and carried on for another
25 minutes saying while everyone's that
they're not hearing a word she said
which seemed struck me now looking back
on it as a the goddess at work that was
just great it's been downhill you have
discussions about all this at home and
work and or arguments about it at home
um discussions and some arguments
although we certainly won't necessarily
my mother and I are in complete
agreement about the importance of
feminism I think what I learned from
that early experience in doing the
survey though was the power of that you
could have as a feminist writer not
being the loudest person on the block
and not being one who you know regularly
interrupted in class or caused a scene I
discovered that through writing I could
make my views heard and I could actually
create change and that was a very
important discovery for me and I think
for a lot of women who are conditioned
not to be rebel rousers on in a public
forum you know not to stand up and in
the public square and make a ruckus but
we can make just as much of a ruckus on
behind the keyboard what about high
school did you write for the newspaper
or were you active in student activities
there I wrote for the newspaper and
continued to make trouble that way what
kind of trouble I'm trying to think of
if there's I mean some of it was of on
feminist grounds quite a bit of it you
know pointing out the usual things that
still exist that women were not women
teachers were not being paid as much as
men that women's sports was not getting
the same attention
I remember if I was on the track team
and we the the girls track team members
would show up dutifully on Saturday and
half the time the coach would just not
arrive because he was too busy with the
boys tracked him so early on I suppose I
inequality of women was an issue that I
kept returning to were you one of those
students that when you walk down the
hallway somebody point at you and say
she's the one causing all the trouble
no I I was um I kept a low profile
well when I walked down the halls I
generally stayed in the office what
about College University work where'd
you go
I went to Harvard and there predictably
it was on the newspaper mm-hmm it was a
managing editor
what's the paper call it's the Crimson
the Crimson and what did you study at
Harvard I studied history and literature
and American history literature when you
went to Harvard how many women were in
your freshman class it was remember the
Ray it was about about 3 to 1 men to two
women what's it today I think it's
almost 54 there may be 50 50 now what
was the attitude at Harvard about women
well
I remember when soon after we my
freshman class arrived that the
Radcliffe appointed a new head of the
Women's Center what's right Radcliffe is
well that was that's a very good point
because Radcliffe and Harvard had merged
but it was one of those mergers where
Radcliffe essentially disappeared from
the scene there was a figurehead
Richard was all West raishin you
Radcliffe used to be all women and with
a merger that it had occurred in the 70s
the Brad Cliff essentially handed over
all of the power and prestige to to
Harvard and and many women
undergraduates would not identify with
Radcliffe at all and so it was very
important that Radcliffe at least serve
as a gadfly and a supporter of women
which brings me back to this little
story about the Women's Center which was
supposed to be promoting feminist cause
of them promoting the education of equal
education of women in that year which
was in the late 70s just as the compact
clash the first backlash breezes were
beginning to come in they appointed a
director and
her first at her first announcement to
introduce herself she said that she
wanted to make it clear that she was not
a feminist and at the time this was very
surprising to me that because that was
still a period when most women I knew at
least on on campus called themselves
feminists and didn't seem the least bit
worried about the consequences but by
the time I graduated and certainly as as
the 80s progressed you had young women
in college became increasingly fearful
of standing up for their rights much
less calling themselves a feminist you
wrote for the Crimson you were the
managing editor the Crimson what year
did you get to that position I think it
was 18 19 80 79 80 something like that
did you find yourself in any kind of a
center of controversy again well there
was a there was a professor who was
notorious as a a sexual harasser and
that year for the first time Harvard
instituted a policy of sexual harassment
and a student decided to file charges
against him and decided to go public
with it and I it fell to me to write the
story and I remember they they actually
in Dean of the college came made a
personal visit to the Crimson which he
did not ordinarily do to urge us not to
run that story and after much debate we
did and the professor went on a sick
leave for six months and I'm sure as
soon as my class graduated he returned
to his post and nothing more was made of
it
but there were feminist issues came up
constantly in that university because
it's notes that mean it's almost a an
envelope of white male power it's where
all of the the men in high this in
positions of power whether it's in
corporate America or in the White House
where many of them were trained kind of
an effort or let me ask you first what
kind of a grade would you give Harvard
with women's issues today well I
actually I was back there to speak at
Radcliffe for the Radcliffe Alumni
lecture and was very very pleasantly
surprised there seemed to be much first
of all there's much more diversity
there's the president of Radcliffe is a
woman who's very committed to advancing
equal education for women and who seems
to be very committed to feminist causes
so it was it was it was a very different
environment from from the one I
encountered twelve years earlier would
you give him an a a B or a see well I
was only there for a day so I what do
you hear about Harvard though I mean
what about in the leadership in the
administration and the deans offices are
women involved to the point where they
should be in your P&L I I think it was
the Chronicle of Higher Education did a
survey recently and found that in 20
years not just at Harvard but across the
board that the proportion of women
tenured faculty has not changed much
and the Ivy League's are the worst I
mean most of them have
if you're lucky 5% of their 5 percent of
their faculty tenured faculty as women
so it's still an uphill battle it's not
as if it's some kind of feminist Mecca
over there he alluded to this earlier on
you're talking about your your fifth
grade performance as a writer as you
went through the grade school high
school and college and certainly now
what power does the printed word have in
the society in your opinion enormous
power and it has the power to harm as
well as what I found out in researching
the backlash
it was the bombardment of story after
story about the wages of feminism that
was largely responsible for so many
women across this country saying to
themselves oh I guess it was a big
mistake for me to want more in life than
you know a white picket fence and a
house in the suburbs you know it was
wrong of me to to have an aspiration or
a dream or to want to participate in
public life you know where did they get
that idea was from it was it was from
the media the outside the the positive
side of that is he one can fight back as
well through a series of Pam and
I think you know that's what we're
seeing for women this year and no in my
book but they've been a whole slew of
feminist writers who have counterpunched
and have have hit the bestseller list as
a result when did you write the last
word I know this was published in 1991
originally but when was the last word
actually written I think probably 89 or
90 how come it took so long to get it
into a book well I kept hauling it back
to add the problem with writing but the
backlashes zone it kept getting worse
and worse and there kept you know new
examples of spewed out on a daily basis
and I kept trying to update it before
the presses were old one of the things
you do in the book is it appears I want
to ask you whether you actually did you
that you ventured into enemy camp that
you interviewed a lot of people who I'll
let you characterize and I'm talking
about Connie Marsh nur who used to be at
the Heritage Foundation Beverly the hey
Concerned Women for America George
Gilder I don't know whether you talked
to Alan bloom or not when you went to
see all those people did they know what
you were doing yes why did they see you
well you know it's this is a question
that probably bedevils all journalists
people want to talk to journalists I
suppose there's something very seductive
about someone sitting there asking you
questions even if they don't agree with
you and also I think they hope to sway
me as well you know and many of them
knew that
I had written pieces for MS magazine and
from other Jones which are not known for
their their right wing writers and they
brought that up in the interviews I
would say well now I know I remember one
one of the women saying well you're very
polite for somebody who's who's written
form is magazine I don't know what she
does miss magazine writers were like but
I think there was just a genuine desire
to to tell their own story and also I
think not very many people had actually
sat down and asked them to speak there's
there's been a lot of commentary about
right-wing activists but not know for a
lot of these people nobody knocked on
their door before what did you find for
instance when you visited Beverly LaHaye
and who is she and who she married to
and kind of explain a little more about
why you went to see her but I didn't go
to Beverly LaHaye's home that elder her
husband is Tim will hey who is one of
the big guns in the in the right-wing
movement in partridge yeah I'm part of
Moral Majority and LaHaye's organization
though I did visit I am Tim it was
actually rather amusing for here we have
a woman who says all women should that
woman's place is in the home and that it
is not in woman's nature to be ambitious
or to on any kind of power and I walk
into her office and which was set up
like the Oval Office you know with the
big flag planted next to the executive
desk and a lot of pictures behind her
Beverly LaHaye shaking hands with Ronald
Reagan and she did have pink curtains up
and she had her business cards were pink
but she was very much a professional
person interested in empower in fact no
one in the organization was allowed to
speak to me or to speak to anybody
without her permission and shortly
before I had arrived in fact she had
appointed herself a president for life
as she put it so there were all these
contradictions that that just leapt out
in front of you when when you set eyes
on just on the setup of her of her
organization what motivates her and she
I mean and what's her philosophy I mean
should women stay home
well she believes well while she
believes that women should stay home in
the middle of this interview her
secretary came in and was going over her
travel plans which would put the average
the average traveling salesman to shame
she had been to Latin America about
fourteen times in the last few years and
I was traveling all over the country
speaking and organizing I think what
drives her though is what drives anyone
who want what drives her is this human
need to be engaged in the public world
to to to experience public life and to
feel as if you are a part of it and as
if you're making some change
okay she was also came from this and
deeply conservative background she did
not want to give that up she and this
was a way
of sort of having her cake and eating it
too of being a being inside that
traditional safe harbor she wasn't
really challenging her community her
conservative religious community in a
way that would make her an outcast but
yet she was also fulfilling her these
basic human needs to get out of the
house be part of the world speak up and
have people listen to you and recognize
you and appreciate you you had any
feedback from any of the people you
wrote about I've had some but not an
enormous amount you know and mostly or I
should say not directly
I think Beverly LaHaye put out a press
release
condemning my evil feminist ways but mmm
I didn't hear from her directly and I
probably will having said that when did
you know on this book actually what was
the first day that it hit the books
doors that was in October 1991 right
such a year ago when did you first know
you had something special her
well it's hard to say I suppose well in
a way it's very ironic because probably
the first inkling was a story in
Newsweek in which they were noting fall
books and they said this book is bound
to be a very talked-about controversial
book and they equated it with The
Feminine Mystique and I say ironic
because probably the publication I took
most to task
and in the book was Newsweek and I think
what happened in this is a very
interesting dynamic that and in a way a
sort of poetic justice the women in the
media who write for the culture pages
the the back of the book as they call it
in the news weeklies where women who
felt as i did in fact the reason they
were in the back of the book is because
many publications in the 70s were forced
to hire women and after a series of
class-action sex discrimination suits
and they said okay we'll hire these
women but we'll stick them in the
women's pages then the women's pages
turned into the arts and books pages so
when a book like mine came out it fell
into the hands of these women who were
very personally familiar with the kind
of discrimination that was going on
inside the media we're as frustrated as
I was and they were the women who
showcased who showcased backlash or was
in Newsweek the reason why I got so much
attention was because there were women
who were feminists at the back of the
book and
so the they embraced backlash because
they made sense to them now in the
middle of all this you left San Jose
Mercury and came to Wall Street join
when did you go to the journal that was
after I had finished backlash I took a
year or year and a half off to finish it
and then I went to the Wall Street
Journal why did they hire you what was
the what was the reason what was the job
I was working in the San Francisco
Bureau and I was hired to write longer
social issues kinds of story so I was
not hired for my knowledge of stocks and
bonds goodness how long were you there a
few years like two years or three years
or about to you to little more than to
you why did you leave well I I left or I
went on leave to handle the demands
surrounding the book and also because I
felt that this was this is a very
unusual and exciting opportunity for
feminists to get the message out that
after so many years of silence we now
have this window of opportunity where
people are willing to talk about
feminist issues where the media is
actually willing to run stories about
women's health about sexual harassment
about also a whole slew of women's
concerns and
in the newspaper and it seemed almost a
crime to say okay well I'm not really
going to participate in any of that now
I'm just going to go back to to writing
about Thai finance so I took a break
from that and I may return night I
haven't decided
okay Newsweek it was the first one to
tip people off the book was coming when
did you next notice more than just her
mentioned in Newsweek that this book was
gonna sell well it began selling very
for happily and I began getting scouts
of letters from women who else jumped on
the bandwagon of reporting it wasn't
just Newsweek was no no I'm trying to
remember and how it was television
appearances there are many television
appearances and I mean it so again it
was a very curious position for me to be
in because one of the things I talk
about in the book is trying to dissect
how a so-called trend story makes the
rounds of the media loop and have say an
idea like post feminism in this notion
that somehow women are now beyond the
women's movement that we're just too
sophisticated and we've gone on into
this survice supposedly hire around when
of course what post a moment that's a
really is this just anti feminism and a
different different pair of clothes and
I talked in the book about how an idea
like that introduced in the media then
gets picked up on television in fashion
ads and comic strips and then after west
backlash became
the phenomenon of its own it went
through this same loop so all of a
sudden I see backlash referred to in in
sitcoms like home improvement it was in
Brenda Starr it was in it was in the
Jehovah's Witness but from the
newsletter and it was curious to see
that same that that same loop begs the
question is whether or not these trends
that the media began and and are thought
out or do they just happen and they once
they take off everybody gets in the act
I think they're largely not thought out
I mean I think there and that was part
of the problem with so many of these
media myths I mean think they start out
by being ideas that fit into certain
preconceptions we have and in the case
of women a lot of the myths of the
backlash were seized upon by the media
because they made sense and some got
level women who ask for too much are
gonna get it and that's something we've
heard over and over again since the
beginning of humankind
so in
respects both men and women in the media
were sitting there thinking when is the
axe courage fall women have been pushing
and pushing women have been radically
changing their role in society surely
there's going to you know there will be
a a punishment for this and so when
stories came along that fit into that
idea such as oh well you'll never get
married or oh you'll never have children
or oh your children are going to be
molested in daycare or oh you're going
to become a crazy a career not who goes
around boiling rabbits like the woman
hidden fatal fatal attraction it fit in
to this this little morality play we all
have in our hand and then once it gets
into the media it's like you know it's
like that spot in the rug where you
scrub it and then it's all over
you only make it worse and I think
that's what happened here too is that
the the idea was almost impossible to to
root out and once it got into our
cultural imagination when was the
decision made to market your book along
with Gloria Steinem to mark it along
with the song yeah we have this
advertisement that I did together I
think that was Gloria steinem's idea or
her publishers idea I can't remember
cover of Time magazine oh I thought you
meant we actually did an ad I know you
did both I mean you ended up on the
cover of Time magazine the cover of Time
magazine that was time approached us and
we got there what did that do to you
well it it certainly made me less of an
anonymous person which i think is a very
difficult position to be in for a writer
or I shouldn't say difficult but
uncomfortable because it makes I think
writers function best when they are
anonymous
and they can be the fly on the wall and
when they're not worried about what
people think of them
once you become a name then you have to
mostly become a public persona then what
comes with that is the idea that you
have to live up to that persona that you
don't want to offend people that you you
know all the baggage that comes with
being somebody who's in the limelight
it's very difficult to write under those
conditions it's very difficult to write
honestly I think is what I was really
saying have you seen I've got the
October edition of the American
Spectator have you seen this yeah I know
I happens you have you seen this really
I think I've heard about it on the cover
this I guess it came out I saw in the
books no one isn't more flattering have
you read it has anybody told you about
no no I haven't are you surprised that a
year later that I can imagine that it's
not in tribute
why can you met me just where it says
wake up little Susie that's the title of
the it's written by a woman by the name
of Mary ever stat she's a contributing
editor of the national interest magazine
you know her I don't know her personal I
know I've heard of her
the sad oneness that says some day that
says just when you thought feminism was
mellowing along comes bad girl Susan
Faludi to do her sulking on the
bestseller lists well this is a very
interesting you know actually if
somebody did send me a Xerox of that
although they kindly didn't Xerox the
front page I didn't recognize it at
first this is a very interesting pattern
that I've recognized recently where
feminists are now accused of being whiny
or in her word sulky and in Forbes
magazine referred to backlash as the
whiners Bible but it's this new way of
attacking feminism which in a way it's
it's the reverse of what they used to do
which is say
feminists are alienating the average
woman by insisting that women all become
the using these super women do
everything be ambitious and be hard
driving executives go for all the power
and now what they're saying is Oh
feminists are turning off the average
women by promoting this super victim
image I was just reading there was an
article the other day was about the
fifth article I've seen in which this
accusation was made that that feminists
are promoting victimhood simply by
drawing attention to it what is insane a
nation of victims and but you know I
think there's a big difference between
pointing out that that women are
attacked on the street and at home and
that's pointing out that the leading
cause of injury to women is battery by
the man they live with there's there's a
big difference in between pointing out
women's condition and endorsing it or
even that do the point of feminism is
not to point out the ways that women are
victimized simply to encourage that
victimization the point is to make women
strong enough to challenge their they're
a victim they're victimizing and that
they almost willfully seem to be
ignoring that in these pieces I mean and
the other thing is whenever women
protest their treatment
it's either written off as hysteria or
it's oh stop complaining stop being a
nag stop whining stop sulking
yeah I'm the only other thing I can say
about that is I I think it would take a
real stretch of the imagination to see
the tone of backlash as sulking who got
the maddest that you know of after bad
guys came out and if you have you had a
confrontation in public and a lot of
that no I how about on television no not
really
when you think about it and I don't
volunteer for television shows in which
you know which are going to lend
themselves due to cab fights
I mean you don't look for I mean
somebody sets up a confrontation you
avoid it I prefer to contact my
confrontations on paper how has that
book changed your life you speak I that
that's one of the big ways in which it's
changed my life and I think a lot of
people who write write because they're
not public speakers because they bombed
out on in the high school in the
audition for their high school play and
I since the book came out I've done a
great deal of public speaking and I
think it's that that has been part of my
own personal feminist evolution as well
to be able not only to project my voice
on paper but to stand up at a public
forum and speak up it's it's an
extremely liberating experience for
women who are not taught that it's a
ladylike to to to take a stand in public
do you have people that you most admire
that are alive today in this kind of a
political movement well certainly Gloria
Steinem why would you what's the reason
well me the number one model if she
combines
in graciousness and humor intelligence
with an incredible as staying power and
I'm you know I'm exhausted after just
the last year and she's been at this for
20-25 years and great admiration for
that but there you know there are so
many feminist activists out there who
get no attention because the press has
this habit of putting three people on
their rolodex and calling them over and
over again there are women you know
across the country whether it's in the
labor union movement or at 9:00 to 5:00
which works for the rights of working
women particularly working-class women
they're women there were women who led
the peace movement during the Persian
Gulf War who really were instrumental in
organizing the peace movement had gotten
to know attention in the press about
women that have been involved in the
feminist movement use it in out
disappointment to you I'm sorry women
that are now a disappointment to you
didn't keep it up and may have changed
their tune I mean you're writes about
some of them they're well you know and
some of those women I've written about
have since serve recharged not that I
take responsibility for that
ready for Dan well in the book I'm
critical of Betty Ford Anne's book the
second the second stage what I'm
critical of is actually of in a sense
her putting down her own movement and
putting down putting putting herself
down because the one of the points
that's made in the second stage is that
the
- of the early 70s late 60s early 70s
didn't do enough to focus on the needs
of women with children and in fact when
you go back and read the nails of
manifesto it's a bill of rights which
Betty Ford and drafted the majority of
those points have to do with with women
with children with working mothers they
the list of demands includes a childcare
maternity leave and then - pregnancy
discrimination and so on and so on and
throughout the seventies and to eighties
it was feminist organizations who were
most committed to advancing the rights
of working mothers
the real enemy to to family needs was
was not the women's movement it was a
Chamber of Commerce and the the
lobbyists for corporations who didn't
want to shell out the money to offer
such programs in the few ministry
everyman let me just touch a couple
bases quickly 106 women were nominated
for the US House of Representatives in
the primary process eleven women for the
Senate your reaction well we will have
to wait and see what happened this
election today but it strikes me that
you can't separate that from everything
else that's gone on this year I mean
what's happened is that women are
furious and they're not going to back
down that in the combination of knowing
that we're at the 11th hour
in the abortion rights battle that
they're standing between us and the
right to have an abortion is one infirm
Supreme Court justice the furor over the
treatment of Nita Hill by the Senate
Judiciary Committee and the awareness
that we are invisible abysmally
represented and in the Senate not to
mention and just about every other
legislative body in this country
provoked women to get out there and run
and it provoked other women to give
money to organizations that fund female
feminist candidates in the last year
donations to Emily's list and other
women's campaign funds more than doubled
so it was this combination of our anger
and our money and rediscovering our
voices that's led to this outpouring of
political activism among women and the
key though is to keep it going beyond
the election day because the media will
you know take the year of the women only
so far and then drop it and look for
another trend and it's up to women to to
force that year into the next year in
the year after that checked how many
times the name Clarence Thomas came up
in your book and found one like it was
page 185 and it was in conjunction with
being chairman of the EEOC it was a
matter of timing of course on this thing
if you had to write this book over again
I think that there would certainly be a
long chapter on Clarence Thomas now were
you surprised that anything that
happened during the Clarence Thomas
Anita Hill hearings based on your
research and the way you see this issue
no in fact I thought it was a a classic
example in in microcosm of how the
backlash works because he had one woman
stand up before a body of men and speak
up and what happened she was pushed back
by a storm of denunciation of ridicule
she was called pathological and she in
her femininity it was called into
question her sanity was called into
question it's and most of all she was
not listened to these are all typical
responses to any woman who stands up and
makes a demand for her rights what's
next I'm at work beginning at the very
beginning of book that is in a sense a
companion to back lashing sort of
jokingly call it son of Pat Clash
because it's if the first book was about
you what is what is a backlash what does
it look like how does it work and
documenting it then the second book will
be looking at why is there why does
there seem to be such hostility and fear
among the male culture and among many
men whenever we see the mere glimmer of
female independence what are the
sociological and psychological
anthropological roots of that kind of
resistance an article in the American
Spectator says that you're getting a
million and a half dollars to write this
next book they say a lot of things they
didn't call me and asked me does it does
it now become more difficult I mean I
assume you're doing much better
financially than they used to when does
that become a drive for you when you see
all this stuff being a success
that's just waking one honey yeah I
never don't ever write to make money if
I was
if making money was the reason I picked
my profession I don't think I would have
picture no listen do you find yourself
changing at all when you start to do
well and your own mind well I'm not not
in any not in any serious way I don't I
mean it's something I'm very conscious
of but since I'm not much of a shopper
and since I don't care much for fancy
cars it hasn't it hasn't transformed my
life in any any any way way worth noting
now is the next 10 years are the next
ten years gonna be better or worse for
women your opinion and they were the
last 10 years shudder to think of them
being worse I think a lot I mean so much
depends on this election because if we
wind up with Bush and if he in turn
appoints the next Supreme Court justice
then we may very well I don't see any
way of preventing it see a roe v wade
overturned and that will just overturn
the whole wheelbarrow for women because
what else do we if we can't determine if
we can't make basic decisions about when
and if and how many children were going
to have what other decisions in our life
can we make everything depends on that
by the way last question who invented
the title for this book I am trying to
remember now it was I just referred to
backlash endlessly in the books that was
sort of the obvious title and I kept
trying to think of a better one and
didn't so he just went with that but it
was actually kind of the fallback title
our guest has been Susan Flutie this is
what the book looks like it's called
backlash it's been in the bookstores for
a year and now in paperback see the
subhead they're the undeclared war
against American women thank you very
much for joining us thank you